[Music]
it was a parade through downtown to
honor heroes
but instead of athletes celebrating a
championship victory
it was essential workers being honored
for bringing new york city
out from a pandemic i'm here for all the
nurses and doctors and everybody that
worked
all this thanks god for them and god
bless them all
thank you you look like you're almost
going to cry
yes i got nieces i got people to die
you know so thanks god bless everybody
[Applause]
there were over 14 floats carrying
nearly 250 types of essential workers
anyone who helped the city get through
its darkest days
and dark days they were in march and
april last year
when new york city was the global
epicenter of the covet pandemic
millions of residents fled in a matter
of days
in all over 33 000 new york city
residents
died from kovid now how times have
changed
the city is now one of the safest places
in the world when it comes to avoiding
the virus
on most days not a single person dies
from covid
thanks to a massive vaccination effort
that to date has administered 4.6
million jabs to city residents
but not everyone is pleased with the
timing of this celebration
the unions that represent new york city
firefighters
emergency medical technicians and
ambulance drivers
called on their members to boycott this
parade
to bring attention to low wages and what
they say
have been no salary increases for over
three years
[Applause]
the festivities also come at a time when
most of the rest of the world is still
in the depths of the pandemic
that was something that was not lost on
spectators
i feel for the other country that is
suffering right now
but in the same sense we are bingen but
we still have to celebrate
for the lives that are alive
in a city that suffered badly but pulled
through and is now saying thank you
to all those who made it happen gabriel
rosando
al jazeera new york